la poésie d'Aragon mise en mouvement
mêlé à celle de Shakespeare être au
paraître de Marie-Claude Pietragalla et
Julien Derouault était l'un des moments
forts d'une journée hommage à Louis
Aragon nous ce qu'on voulait à
l'occasion de se 40e anniversaire de la
mort d'Aragon c'était retrouver laragon
qu'on connaît un petit peu et en même
temps faire découvrir faire toucher du
doigt la pluralité des visages d'Aragon
dans les jardins du Moulin de Villeneuve
le poète français disparu le 24 décembre
1982 a été célébré ce premier octobre
entre lecture rencontre et concert pour
les amoureux des mots célèbres ou moins
célèbres je l'ai connu quand j'avais 18
ans et ma plus quitté je l'ai connu par
un roman qui s'appelle la mise à mort et
après j'ai lu sa poésie après j'ai lu sa
critique d'art et après j'ai lu je
suivais son journal
Aragon c'est
tout ces textes roman ou poèmes
c'est la musique c'est c'est la vie
c'est avec ces double sens toujours
Aragon c'est on amène à réfléchir je
suis venu de Rennes
ouais carrément et puis on s'est dit bah
oui toute une après-midi soirée enfin
voilà parce que oui porté par tout le ce
texte d'Aragon à plusieurs voix en fait
chanter ce soir par Juliette et puis là
dans la journée des poètes tous aussi
bouleversant les uns que les autres les
célébrations continuent jusqu'à la fin
de l'année avec l'exposition Claude
Viala et de manière numérique avec la
chaîne Youtube de la maison Triolet
Aragon